this is something that we didn't really
get to what and at this point you know
i think this news has gotten buried with
all the uh
other stuff going on the um
royal youtube channel yeah can we watch
it it's only like 40 seconds right
you know the duke and duchess like like
you [ __ ] need a youtube channel
get uh just even without watching get
over yourselves
you live in a castle you have like an
entire country
that just like oh my god
the royal family what more do you need
these self-important [ __ ] can can i say
i don't know much about the royal family
again i don't know if this is his look
or whatever but why doesn't my man just
go fully bald
yeah what's up with this yeah what's up
with the old man haircut i don't know
man
shave it all off dude you could be a
nice young bald guy
what's with that i don't know
anyways let this rip by the way you'll
be careful what you're saying now
because these guys they're filming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean it's a really bad trailer yeah
they already don't get it
yeah yeah by the way you would be
careful
how many how many subscribers okay 442
subscribers
442 thousand no 442 i'm just going to
downplay them as much as possible
okay what what is that first video they
posted shielding what
shielding mila holds what is this goofy
grammarly helps you
[Music]
i don't care yeah off let's get some
reaction videos you you guys really
created a youtube channel to post
ken burns slide shows get off this
platform you have no idea what you're
talking about i mean
yeah what would you rather i'd rather
than do like you know
the classics like the baby dropping
pranks yeah do a baby dropping prank
like the actual real fan yeah go to the
classic [ __ ] go to the hood and do
something wrong
yeah do something that's gone wrong in
the hood
[Laughter]
hey today so i bought what's her name
the duchess
whatever yeah today i bought the duchess
a brand new iphone you guys
but here's the thing i'm gonna break it
in front of her but what you guys don't
know
is that i bought her another one and
we're gonna give it to her
right after she freaks out you guys i'm
so excited all right
hey darling
hi hello babe how was your day
was good i waved to some children
i ate a strawberry okay cool i got you a
new iphone babe
it's the purple one it's lovely oh and
now it's on the ground
wait wait wait i got you another one i
love you it's the same color
thank you for watching the royal family
vlogs make sure to smash that like
button
smash it like you smash the phone oh my
god
[Music]
cheerio
[Laughter]
get out of here bro this is not
i love this i love this they're trying
to engage
the unfiltered part this is like you
know internet is
for the most part pretty unfiltered and
i love that every day there's going to
be some bozo who's tasked with deleting
comments that are like
ah this sucks duke and duchess of these
balls
y'all rocking with the duke of these
nuts like you know what i mean like it's
just
shitty comment after shitty comment yep
what are some of the comments on these
videos do you even allow comments
oh yeah can't wait for the royal mukbang
vid
yeah just oh man i just
[ __ ] you know just crumpets
[Laughter]
that was an actual [ __ ] not that anyone
cares what i have to say
just crumpets you [ __ ] idiot
why do i think about this stupid [ __ ]
telling my parents that they're actually
related frank gone wrong
see yeah um
okay and now for the sponsor of today's
video
manscaped what that's kind of funny
honestly yeah and it's him shaving the
sides of his [ __ ] head
finally i've used the new ball trimmer
it's going to work amazingly on my head
because my scalp is
commensurate with my bowls that's not
going to work
but well my next video calling
calling prince philip at 3 am
a trigger warning very emotional
that's good yeah sometimes youtube
comments are good man yeah oh i mean i
already tweeted this [ __ ]
yeah looking reacting to the oprah video
what is up guys it is the duke and
duchess here as you all know
my little brother and his stupid
girlfriend were
talking [ __ ] so i'm gonna watch it here
today with you guys
comment down below if you think i should
box my brother i think he's a massive
[ __ ]
you know i'm older than him anyways
let's get into it
interview starts and he's like okay
chill out oprah
trying to get into the mix calm down
first of all it didn't go down like that
i don't even know you don't
you don't know what really goes on all
right all you guys see is like what we
what we put on the screen but you don't
know what really goes on behind the
scenes
all right so if you could just be
respectful of our privacy that'd be
great and don't come to the
palace yeah absolutely do not come to
the palace you guys are always outside
and to be honest
i'm gonna it's kind of [ __ ] annoying
we can never go outside like sometimes
just want to go out and chill and
you guys are there like dude we
appreciate the love and everything
and like we're so grateful that you guys
are like fans of us and that you buy our
merch and stuff like that but
don't come to the palace seriously
respect our privacy
but if you are part of my little
duchesses fan club
you're always allowed at the palace as
long as you let me know first
ah comment down below if you're part of
the little duchess's fan club anyway
let's get back into it
[Laughter]
by the way guys we're gonna be
facetiming one fan
and that's it and that's it
[Laughter]
just won every year
so make sure you hit that sub button
yeah i don't know man i'm just
i just don't get what they want to do
here
you know like like when will someone
imagine them doing an iphone giveaway
bro oh they just started doing all the
just everything
yeah uh what else um
oh my i was about to make a bad joke
that's
no it's fine i'll leave that one alone
i'll say it but we have to cut it no
it's fine
it's fine
yeah i'm trying to think of other you
know basic youtube i mean baby dropping
prank
iphone smashing prank iphone giveaway
uh what else oh
we brought 10 poor people into the
palace and we let
them decide who gets 10 000 pounds
so today we've got 10 commoners inside
we fully sanitize them so they can't
infect us and
we've put our 10 000 quid and they're
all going to decide who gets the quid
so away they go yeah i don't know
jubilee cut um palace shorts
palace what do you mean oh yeah nice
little 15 seconds yeah just
little bangers yeah yeah
this is how i make my crumpets [ __ ] dude
why do i say that
yeah yeah what what else all those
shorts i feel like would be really
plastic
hello this is my short and i'm having
loads of fun
another day in the palace and i'm loving
it
and i'm wearing shorts i've worn shorts
for the shorts
see it just reminds me of that clip
where
uh some some uh
like news network i think abc was pumped
with this story that
she was rated as having the most
attractive face
you remember that no it was like it was
like oh it's because of her nose
they like did some analysis on her nose
and it's so
funny because two of the anchors are
like oh yeah
there's two other anchors they're like
yeah i don't i don't know about all that
yeah it's just like i don't know these
people are so attention starved bro it
drives me crazy
i don't
yeah again i don't really have any
contacts about the royal family
they just like they just dominate
tabloids in
the uk and and it's like even
even with megan and uh what's the dude's
name
harry yeah yeah whatever
harry styles like even though coming
over here like you know there's
thousand meg in the stallion
you know that they couldn't handle it
they were like how
dare they get american publicity before
us
yeah how do we beat this we make a
youtube channel
youtube we make a youtube channel chick
choc
chick chocolate
we make a chick choc what
chick choc i'm just trying to think of
other words as big as dentures would
collide together on twitch
we've made a chick chock a twitch
channel
as well as an only fans
yeah if they're gonna make something
mega only fans bro
yeah so let's see you guys oh god
you're [ __ ] disgusting what them
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
be awful man i don't see that guy [ __ ]
anything
oh yes oh yes yeah right
right right okay
quiet
[Music]
yes right unequivocally
yes commensurate
absolutely commensurate
that's bloody commensurate
yeah no we said this in the uk i know
british at least you know british people
[ __ ] for the most part is just like
you all right it's nice okay
yeah let me know if you need anything
you're right yeah it's nice quite nice
quite nice [ __ ] you're right yeah
you're all right
yeah you're right yeah oh i'm all right
i'm all right
am
it doesn't sound the same it doesn't it
really doesn't and i'm just thinking of
some
brash english still being like yeah you
like it
you like it when i ran my two fingers in
your [ __ ] yeah
you like it when i'm deep in your [ __ ]
or mouth and i'm rub on your clitoris
just like that yeah
all right let's bang on what you're
doing right there with your tongue yeah
that's bang on love it oh you see the
way she does that yeah just suckling on
the head right there
oh yeah you squirted two points
[Laughter]
fill a cot with that one huh all right
she's a rock at that one
squinting all over the place
[Laughter]
she's coming in my bedroom she's come
everywhere
i don't know man it's been entirely a
little bit on this one it's just
i can't believe you've done this i can't
believe you've done this
that's that's what they say yeah when
the type is crazy oh i can't believe
you've done this i can't believe you've
done it i can't believe you've done this
mate okay that is unequivocal
i can't believe you're doing this that's
got to be it's got to be interesting
there's a woman in the uk being called
mate
and uh what's like um
it's like a what's the word in australia
the isn't there like some term kind of
like mate don't they use mate as well
yeah
might it's gotta be crazy to be called
oh yeah mate calling a girl mate
what she's [ __ ] your dick oh you're
made
that's nice yeah it's like i'm not your
mate
yeah you are mate
she get with her she mate zoned me yeah
she major oh
bomber that's more english
yeah do you know what right she might
join me
she put me in the mate zone
[Laughter]
she put she put me in them she put me in
a mate zone
did they say that mid zone mate nice
that's stupid
and we're gonna get one comment actually
it's not
i've made sound is very real i mean it
now
yeah i wanna i'm gonna i'm gonna do that
to alina wait what is your like a mate
zone on urban dictionary mate zone what
is it zoom in
when when the guy you like calls you
mate he's friend zoning you like
like an australian there you go you're
really
you want to do a dramatic reading of
this yeah sure
go ahead you're really attractive brad
thanks mate i think i just got mate zone
oh blimey
[Laughter]
yeah the only other one is when
[Music]
uh the only like inverse of that is when
a girl from boston
calls you bro yeah sucking your penis
yeah bro
yeah bro you like that i can't remember
a boston accent
i just know at our show there half the
women in that crowd signing like 1964
like chevy engines
[Music]
yeah bro
anyway